what unique can you bring to the table
because that's going to help you to grow
so much if you're just trying to be the
next jake paul he's already done it it's
already successful don't have that
mindset of like oh it's too late or
someone else is already doing it like of
course someone else is already doing it
and if you are trying to find something
very specific on youtube and it's not
out there create it yourself because we
obviously like youtube has got so many
videos if you found something that does
not exist
you just hit like a landmine there like
run with it
if you're just getting started on
youtube and you've typed into the
youtube search bar how to start on
youtube how to make money on youtube how
much does youtube pay me you've
definitely come across catherine manning
she's one of the top youtube educators
right now with her own style of how
she's creating content i'm excited
because this is a two-part series we're
doing with catherine manning and today
we're talking all about the youtube
algorithm how to grow and how to make
money on youtube my name is heather
torres and i'm the host of the think
media podcast the number one podcast to
help you grow your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit online business
and today we're getting into a two-part
series so if you missed the last episode
make sure to go back and listen to it we
talked all about how to pick your niche
the mindsets to overcome and how to do
branding right on youtube so if you
missed that make sure to go back and
listen to it well if you're a catherine
fan like i am you're gonna love this
episode because she really dives into
pieces of her story that she hasn't told
before what it really takes to become
successful on youtube and how to
actually figure out this whole youtube
thing the algorithm how to make money
all of that is in today's episode let's
jump into today's featured content and
then we'll wrap it up after the content
for some reflective questions and more
[Music]
one of the things you're big on is
teaching people
learning the algorithm understand how
youtube works
you
now have the results you have the case
studies you a lot of times share your
analytics
but would you what advice would you have
on that like early on is it a priority
to to really learn youtube and what have
you learned about the youtube algorithm
yeah i would say from the beginning for
one just start okay i i've gotten so
many comments in the past from people
being like i'm just trying to learn as
much as possible before i get started
and i'm like you need to get started and
then learn as much as possible because i
think you need to learn
how like okay what are you gonna create
videos about what topics do you actually
like talking about
what's your editing going to be like
like what's going to be the style of
your thumbnails all of that stuff before
you can really use the algorithm because
if you are creating what i'm going to
call crappy videos which all of our
videos at the beginning are crap i left
mine up there they're so bad you can
watch them they're terrible but if you
are using the algorithm and you're
trying to get those videos to go viral
i would honestly just use like the first
two months as a learning curve of
figuring out filming and editing and
possibly thumbnails and all of that
stuff before you really dive into okay
how do i find keywords and where do i
place keywords and all of that
got it and you gotta just punch fear in
the face punch perfectionism in the face
press record
and you don't have the data until you've
actually posted enough videos
to to uh
to learn what is it um
what is your advice when
it comes to developing that initial
upload strategy
um a schedule for your content if you're
encouraging somebody knowing now what
you knew then
um how long it takes to initially learn
how to film how to edit
you now do all that yourself correct
yeah i do but you had to learn it all so
what what how was that process for you
uh
okay so i got started with a really
shaky camera that did not have a flip
out screen i couldn't see myself i
didn't have like a connection to like
put it on a monitor or something to see
myself so
it was really bad like the quality of my
videos was just absolutely terrible but
it was the camera that i had i thought
it was better than using my phone
looking back i would have just got
started with my phone especially the
phones that are out now the quality of
the camera is so dang good like that's
all you need you don't need any fancy
really
advanced equipment to get started
obviously now i've got lights and i've
got too many cameras it's ridiculous but
as you grow and as you have more money
to invest back in your channel make sure
that you're investing it back in your
channel but
what was the question what were we
talking about yeah like i mean just was
it intimidating to start editing
were you slow at first and did you um
did you take any courses on it did you
just what software did you start with do
you use the same software today
i mean how cause that's very
intimidating it's like okay new camera
um you know and you just did you just
dive in and was it smooth or was it kind
of frustrating did you have to persevere
or what was your experience
yeah so i had an ipad pro i didn't even
have a computer because i started
youtube as a side hustle so i had a
i don't even know what kind of laptop it
was but it was not a mac laptop for
business use so i couldn't use that for
my youtube channel because that was just
for my full-time job at the time so i
edited on my ipad and imovie comes for
free on any apple device so i got
started with imovie on my ipad and that
was so challenging not as many features
are available on the ipad but at the
same time when i was just getting
started i did very minimal edits like
all i did was cut out some of my ums or
where i made mistakes
that was it like i didn't add any sound
effects i didn't add any music in the
beginning it was very very rough it
wasn't until i got i have like an imac
desktop computer that i was still using
imovie but i became a bit more advanced
and i went from taking maybe 20 minutes
to edit to two hours to edit and now
depending on the video i mean i'm
spending like eight hours to edit a
video depending on how many features
overlays sound effects music like
everything else that goes into it so
it's definitely a learning curve i
didn't take any courses i just went to
youtube i mean youtube has everything
for free if you want to learn how to
edit go to youtube and are you still on
imovie
i'm on final cut pro now
awesome and we'll actually you know
nolan moulton think media team literally
has a two hour class like you said on
final cut pro on think media that'll
teach you everything you need to know
and more i mean he gets crazy deep into
like color grading and all kinds of
stuff and so we'll link that up in the
show notes if um
you want to check that out and i like i
think what you broke down is really
great advice
you know starting with what you have
starting simple and not letting even
your edits be too complex not letting
anything be too complex at first but you
can level up as you go and reinvest in
your channel as you go
um and
today you're on a mac
and you're on final cut
i would echo that if somebody said hey
sean tell me what computer to buy
if i was saying pc or or or mac i would
say mac i don't know if you'd say the
same thing and i would say i think
imovie is a good place to start a final
cut because mac workflow is more
user-friendly
it's a nice you know it's a great system
i love both but if if you're listening
to this and you're like on the fence
trying to make a decision i think
staying in the mac world is uh is the
use most user-friendly world uh what do
you think about that would you give that
same advice to a friend if you if
they're like hey i want to get a camera
and get a computer what would you tell
them to invest in
yeah i've actually gotten that question
before is camera versus computer and i
always say computer because with your
computer like imovie comes for free so
you're not only getting a computer which
you can do so many different things with
but it also comes with an editing
software like i ended up getting final
cut when i had my youtube channel
for
two and a half years like i had been
editing hundreds of videos already on
imovie for free it's a great platform
but a camera i mean obviously it's going
to give you a good quality visual but if
you have an iphone or something just get
started with your iphone like the
quality on that is so incredibly good
compared to
i mean if you're trying to if you have a
nice computer and you're not a nice
computer if you have a nice camera and
you're trying to edit on your iphone
i've done that before where i created a
whole video editing on my iphone and
it's so much harder to do i would just
recommend just like
get the computer get the computer and
imac is definitely the way to go
today you are katherine manning and you
were yesterday as well but you're
katherine manning with 440 000
subscribers and you're getting thousands
of views and you mentioned your first
videos are your worst videos but you got
to just start
if you think through what's different
about your videos now and you say what i
wish i knew
uh if i was starting of course you got
to start messy so i get that but if
there's some ways to level up our videos
what are the distinctions that go
through your mind now
in terms of making a video hold
attention average view duration matters
you know be more interesting be more
engaging what are some of the elements
that go into a catherine manning video
that helps to get the results that it
gets
yeah so
one of the things i know we mentioned
this like level up as you go but one of
the things that i did is with every
video i tried to learn something new or
just become better and better and that's
why when i was first getting started
like my edits were so incredibly simple
and then i was like okay let's try sound
effects okay let's try different
transitions and all of that stuff will
come so when i first got started all of
my videos my camera was in one place the
whole time and i was sitting in one
place the whole time and i was just
talking the edits were simple
very boring basic video but you all got
to start from somewhere so now
i realized like sean mentioned i really
enjoy lifestyle content and when i was
watching youtube tips videos i felt like
a lot of people were sitting in one
place sometimes they had different
camera angles but those videos weren't
what am i saying we're extremely
informative but we're not that
entertaining so with all of my videos i
move my camera around a ton i get a
bunch of different shots and i try to
make it more of that lifestyle feel
while also having it be informative
yeah do i i mean i think that you might
start in your in your kitchen have i
ever seen you like grab ice and put it
into like an iced iced tea or so you
have a couple cut so you're almost
weaving like vlog elements
into something that's still educational
yes and that's what you mean when you
say lifestyle content
yeah yeah so the way that i looked at it
is i wanted to like set the scene so
sometimes if i'm gonna have i've got a t
here but if i wanted to have a t in the
video while i'm talking i would actually
have the intro of me putting water into
my keurig and then putting the tea bag
into my cup and putting the cup on my
keurig and the whole entire process and
it is like a nice little intro to help
you set the scene of how you got to me
sitting here i've also done the same
thing with me like setting up my
equipment showing that whole process and
then hit record and i mean it's
recording the whole time of me showing
like the setup but it just it adds more
interest in my opinion and it kind of
captures people from the beginning
showing them your environment so that's
something you guys want to do i
definitely recommend it
yeah and of course check out catherine's
channel for some examples those elements
are critical because they sound like
they might just be fun and that matters
and entertainment of that matters but
it's that average view duration
videos being more interesting that can
give you an edge to getting a video
shared in the algorithm and growing your
channel
um you know we're on a mission here to
help 10 000 uh purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love on youtube you've you're
living the dream i mean you you are
um
able to you bought a house
congratulations and thank you um you
know you're you're doing this full-time
you get to express you've turned your
creativity into a career
um
i'm curious
in a second let's talk about kind of
like how you turn this into a business
how how does the money come in where
where how do you pay the bills because
there's so many different paths to that
but i'm just kind of curious what does
it feel like
today with the success that you have
compared to also maybe
when you are in the struggle because
there's no there's no way to get to
success without struggle or sacrifice
what comes to mind of maybe hard times
when you wanted to quit and then and
then how do you feel today with what
you've achieved so far
yeah i mean it's crazy so when i got
started with my brand i got started
because i was in
a terrible depressive state where i just
hated everything like i was a really
negative person and i was just
absolutely miserable with my life and i
was like it has to get better like there
has to be something more out there for
me it just it has to get better so one
of the first things i did is i bought my
website and then i ended up moving to a
different city and there's been kind of
like a snowball effect of things that
i've done along the way to create this
life that i have myself now but
yeah i pinch myself
all the time and it's crazy yesterday i
was changing a light fixture because i
absolutely love house projects and
just like improving my house in little
ways to make it my own and i changed
that light and i was like wow
it's crazy because a few years ago i
wouldn't have even been able to afford
that light and it was only like a
hundred dollars it wasn't much but
that simple thing that brought me joy i
was like wow i didn't have this even
just a few years ago so yeah when i
first got started i mean i wasn't making
a lot of money i got started with this
with my side hustle and then i moved
into it full time and i ended up jumping
in too early to the point where i ended
up going the massive credit card debt
and it was it was bad it was terrible
but i ended up building myself out of it
in 2020 i paid all of it off and now i'm
debt free minus my house which is such a
blessing that's amazing so you
went all in
without another job so you could work on
it full-time and coverage your bills
with credit cards in those early days
yeah so i ended up i made the transition
into freelancing and i had a client take
me on that said that they were going to
keep me for like six plus months and
that client the amount of money i was
making was equivalent to what i was
making with my full-time job and it was
only 20 hours a week so i was like this
is great i can dedicate the rest of my
time to building like my content side of
things and that client after a month
ended up having a hiring freeze which
meant that they had to let go all of
their contractors and freelancers so i
lost that income so i ended up taking on
other clients but it wasn't enough money
for me so whatever money i was making
was going towards my bills and stuff at
the time like i had to pay for my water
and my garbage and everything else that
you got to pay for you know and then all
of my spending was going on my credit
cards and really it was like i cut my
spending totally once i realized i was
building up credit card debt but still
paying for
like my
email provider all of that stuff
uh oh my gosh what am i paying for like
quickbooks and just like a variety of
different subscriptions and things that
you need like i wasn't buying equipment
or anything but just general business
expenses like my domains having my
hosting all of that was going on credit
cards and that really builds up
especially after a year of like not
making barely any money it it was bad
did you feel like that was kind of like
uh a kick in the pants to make things
work were you super driven during that
time and
buy that because it was about a year of
that season until
was the tipping point of them making
enough to start paying that down
yeah so i ended up
i had a tipping point where i thought
that i was gonna need to get another job
and i ended up going and driving with
grubhub and that was a way for me to
keep doing what i was doing i still had
clients i was making very minimal money
with affiliate marketing and i had paid
products at the time but it allowed me
to still do that while then also making
some money that i needed to make so i
drove with grubhub i think for like four
months until i was like i don't want to
do this like i would rather be working
with clients i would rather be working
on my brand i need to find a way to make
this work so i ended up taking on more
clients where then i was making a couple
thousand dollars a month which was
enough for me that's all i needed i was
making like 3 000 a month and i was like
this is great that's awesome and then a
few months later my youtube channel
started to grow and take off and i went
from making that three thousand dollars
a month to like fifteen thousand dollars
a month before i knew it so it really
skyrocketed for me but like a real kick
in the pants was
i had my sister come to me
with just like a desperate moment where
she was like i need you
i'm going through this rough time i need
you and i was like i don't have the
money i was like i've got two credit
cards that are maxed out i'm not making
money i can't do it and for me i was
like i don't want to be broke anymore i
don't want to be here i don't want to do
this so i really got my act together and
that
i mean that ended up helping to
skyrocket my youtube channel because i
was so focused on finding ways of
actually making it work
thank you for sharing that story and so
today and even during that time you've
now built out a couple different
significant income streams and so
um
what is it today
that uh what was it then i mean was it
youtube ad revenue was the first thing
and then what was kind of the journey
and what are your core monetization
strategies today
yeah so in the beginning the most money
i was making was with freelancing so i
was taking on clients and i was doing a
lot of
consulting i was doing pinterest work
seo work what i really knew at the time
i was doing that work for clients so
that was my primary income stream and
then i also had affiliate marketing i
was making maybe a hundred dollars a
month maybe i wasn't even monetized at
that time with my youtube channel so i
was just pushing out videos without
getting paid at all i wasn't taking on
any sponsorships and
really that was it like i was not making
a lot of money at that time it was just
freelancing and then over time because
my youtube channel grew so much my ads
revenue ended up skyrocketing but also i
had laid the foundation for my affiliate
marketing so a bunch of my videos
already had affiliate marketing links i
was already creating videos that the
main goal was to promote my affiliate
links and get some sales there so once
my channel took off so did my affiliate
marketing links and like i started
making really really good money with
affiliates and then it ended up
sponsorships came in later on i waited a
while to take on some sponsorships
because i didn't want to do it right
away i wanted to focus on my content and
now sponsorships is another good income
stream for me and what kind of
affiliates were you an affiliate for
yeah so i've got at the beginning
because i was talking a lot about
pinterest so tailwind which is an
automation platform for pinterest that
was a big one for me tubebuddy all heard
of tubebuddy before
uh what were some other ones i was
honestly like very minimal at the
beginning convertkit my email platform
it was all like products and it was
really the services that i was using
because i wasn't really
referring to like amazon or anything
from my camera gear or anything like
that so it was really just the services
i was using
and then once you started getting some
decent views youtube ad revenue became
significant
what uh
what does that become like today off off
like a half a million a million views
that you get a month today what are you
earning
about
uh between like seven and ten thousand a
month just from ads
that's amazing and uh thanks for sharing
that too i think you do share that on
your channel that's a great question
like hey tell me exactly
how much and if i could have your social
security number as well and uh your bank
account number oh oh people are on the
podcast listening no so
uh
i love it you know and it's encouraging
because we will learn that um this isn't
overnight it takes perseverance it's
hard seasons um you got to have a vision
it's cool to hear
you know a family member needed help and
it was like man i don't want to be broke
you know i want to keep fighting for
this and it's cool to see the results
that you've um gotten today what's the
future uh what are you looking to next
personally i'm sure you have your own
business goals um but we've been looking
at a lot of you know the big popular
term now as the creator economy which is
what it's been but now that's language
that's being thrown around uh there's a
cool report that we sort of shared some
details on from the tilt on
what they're calling content
entrepreneurs and i would say you know
you are one of those and it's that
there's some real language signal fire
revealed this is the fastest growing
type of small business so i'm curious
two two-part question
what do you see the future for you
personally because you're you're moving
forward from where you've already
arrived but also what do you see as the
future for those listening and that you
know right now of course comparison
competition
youtube being crowded
do you feel like there's still
opportunity do you feel like the next
few years this next decade uh what do
you think about the landscape of just
this idea of being a content creator and
doing some of what you're doing let's
start first with what you think about uh
maybe for
um yourself and then and then how you
feel like it is in general for other
people what's the future for catherine
yeah for me
funny enough i was talking about this
today on my instagram stories because i
used to think i was going to be one
thing you know at first i was like i'm
going to be a motivational speaker and
i'm going to do that and then i was like
no i'm just going to be a course grader
and i'm just going to be behind the
scenes and now i'm at the point where
it's like i'm trying to figure out what
i want to do because i love just being a
content creator like i love just
creating videos i love talking to my
audience and trying to figure out the
next big thing for me i'm like what what
is next i'm not exactly sure one of the
things i've always wanted to do though
is to host a retreat i want to do an
all-inclusive retreat where it's like
yeah maybe we'll talk about youtube but
i also want to have like meditation and
yoga and talk about like food and like a
bunch of different things that are also
important to creating success for
yourself so i would absolutely love to
do that hopefully in the next few years
but we'll kind of see what the world
looks like
and that's powerful because that's you
essentially that's what's amazing about
this industry is once you get some
momentum and you get some revenue and
you have some influence it is kind of
like a canvas you're an artist that can
take it whatever direction that you want
do you want to write a book or do you
want to host to retreat or do you want
again assuming you have some people
you've built a connection with you've
got a thousand true fans you certainly
have done that and so
uh the future is is a place of
abundant
creativity what do you think in general
people are just getting started though
right now and it seems crazy we're going
into 2022
and like man
youtube is
is no longer uh a young kid youtube
started in 2005. so we're coming up on
youtube's the 16 17 year old just got
its license
still living at home but super
rebellious you know mom and dad i don't
want advice from you anymore uh you know
youtube's like
and and yet there's never been a bigger
audience but what's your general thought
on this creator con economy conversation
this being the fastest growing small
business type and what maybe
encouragement or even advice
because navigating these waters is maybe
different than when you started it's
different than when i started you're
telling somebody who's maybe like
looking at this mountain of of climbing
up in the crater economy and feeling a
little overwhelmed or feeling like i
want some wisdom from the now no longer
24 catherine manning
what can
what can old catherine manning coach me
on
she's been around she's she's got a few
scars
now and she's gonna guide me
so uh yeah what are your thoughts on on
the future this next decade that's how i
feel i finally feel old enough to offer
some advice to some people you know
no i
i think if tick tock has taught us
anything like it's not too late to get
in the game you know
anyone can blow up on tick tock and it's
amazing and i
i feel like since like 2019 2020 i don't
know i've been seeing these videos all
the time where people are like is it too
late to start youtube
i don't think it's ever too late to
start youtube honestly and if i would
have waited i would have just been one
year behind where i am today or two
years behind where i am today you know
like depending on when i got started so
if you think about it if you start today
you're going to be
so much further along than where you
would be if you waited and you had all
the right equipment or you had the money
to buy the equipment or all the
information or you took all these
courses whatever it is like you just
kind of have to get started today and
figure it out as you go but
i don't think i i think yes it's
oversaturated there's a lot of people
like i'm not going to deny there are a
lot of creators out there but that
doesn't mean that we don't need you as a
creator like we don't need another think
media we don't need another catherine
manning we're already doing it
what unique can you bring to the table
because that's going to help you to grow
so much if you're just trying to be the
next jake paul he's already done it he's
already successful what new can you
bring like you could be the next jake
paul if you came up with something
different you know so i just kind of
think
you got to get started don't be afraid
don't have that mindset of like oh it's
too late or someone else is already
doing it like of course someone else is
already doing it and if you are trying
to find something very specific on
youtube and it's not out there create it
yourself because we obviously like
youtube has got so many videos if you
found something that does not exist
you just hit like a land mine there like
run with it
i love that and i just want to
acknowledge you as well you know i like
um
it's awesome to see you create content
obviously you
are teaching things and sharing things
and doing lifestyle content outside of
this youtube teacher kind of space but
you're also a newer youtube teacher and
i love that fact because you could have
said well think media is doing it and
tim schmoyer is doing it and derral eves
is doing it and roberto blake's is doing
it and sonny leonard is doing it but but
like it also showed that if even if
somebody else is already doing it
you can too
like if you get started you bring and
then you brought a different flavor to
it you said man everyone's doing it this
way i'm going to bring a little
lifestyle edge to it i'm going to bring
my own style to it in fact i'm going to
stop watching everybody else and i'm
going to do it in my own way so whatever
your niche is i'm sure if you're
listening to this you could identify
competitors
you can learn from them but maybe you
need to stop watching them and follow
katherine's advice and just be you
um and you'll never know if you don't
try and really even the data is showing
us there's 2.3 billion monthly active
users on youtube now
the audience
are more conditioned to consume content
even than ever before catherine here was
a big lightbulb moment for me
my parents my mom susan and my stepdad
phil
um weren't really watching youtube they
never really watched my videos but
really because of the pandemic
they they installed this projector in
their living room with that had like an
alexa on it yeah and all of a sudden my
wife and i come over with our son sean
bradley
and they're like
guys
you would not believe these youtubers we
discovered and i was like
stop
you're on
they're in their 70s they're and they're
literally like check out this couple and
it's this couple that
covers uh famous songs and different
outfits and and they sing these songs on
their car and there's like these
montages maybe you've seen somebody like
them yeah but i'm i'm sitting there and
i'm like did my mom just say
you need to check out these new
youtubers i've discovered
so besides it being one of the most
entertaining and amusing evenings of my
life and uh i was just delighted by the
fact this is happening my dad's like
switches to snowboard stuff like hey
look how cool you know it what it showed
me though
was was again more people are coming on
every day for some people this is their
first day coming on youtube we're now
seeing the stats that multi-generation
gen x baby boomers they're on youtube of
course gen z millennials and and across
the board uh it's this next decade's
gonna be the best decade catherine i'm
so grateful for you thank you for um
being here today uh of course your links
will be in the show notes but just give
a shout out if people want to connect
with you
follow you where are you most active
there's your youtube channel and
anywhere else
yeah so i've got my youtube channel
catherine manning i also have catherine
manning vlogs if you just want behind
the scenes or just fun day in my life
stuff it's very chill over there but
also on instagram catherine underscore
manning said that i could not just get
katherine manning which is a bummer but
katherine underscore manning i'm active
on my instagram stories every single day
so if you just want to come hang out
that's where you can find me catherine
manning thank you
yeah thanks for having me
well that wraps up this two-part series
with katherine manning and i love what
she said at the beginning of this
episode she said don't try and learn all
the things and then start
start and then learn all of the things
so good catherine thank you so much for
being a part of this episode and did you
enjoy it let us know over on our podcast
rating and review you can do that by
going to apple leaving a comment rating
and reviewing this podcast let us know
if you liked episodes like this and when
you and if you like when we bring on
other guests other youtube trainers
other authors and speakers onto this
podcast today's podcast shout out goes
to cray8 blue skies they said genuine
love the compassion to help others the
think media team really comes across as
everyday people with genuine dedication
to help others grow in the youtube space
and really so much beyond that oh my
goodness thank you so much i'm like best
comment of the day right there that
makes my heart so happy because that's
our mission here at think media we want
to help 10 000 purpose-driven
entrepreneurs create a uh influence
online through the power of online video
that is you and i'm so excited that
you're here and you're listening and
that you're a part of this think media
community it means so much to us you
rated and reviewed the podcast and i
can't wait to read more on the upcoming
episodes well if you haven't already
registered for our think master class we
have a brand new free class for you if
you take in some other classes that we
have you'll want to make sure that you
register for this new one this one is
all about learning how to generate over
57 000 views per day with this one
strategy make sure you register for that
class at
thinkmasterclass.com well thank you so
much for being a part of this community
make sure you subscribe wherever you're
consuming this content from and we'll
catch you on the next episode bye
you